how about when I pulled up today my boys
at cousins Maine lobster the truck was
up I saw it they yeah they yell out to
me well I can't turn down a [ __ ]
grilled cheese did you get one just now
yeah well they were like hey and so they
yell at you because there's no window
there so that's weird
in other words I don't think that the
only I'm just asking a question cuz if
you look at that side of it that's the
side that I saw no if you could turn it
the others the other way there's that
see there I don't know what where'd they
yell from you hmm
it might be I'm just asking I don't know
it might be a lobby Moscone to me cuz
that's the side that was facing
everybody so yeah I know it's weird
right
they stick more as fewer the lobsters
that folds down don't think something
there you'll have well maybe they do
have to try it I don't know they didn't
yell although I want cousins Maine
lobster right now hopefully there won't
you for know what makes it so good is
that white bread the Texas toast that
[ __ ] Texas toast that [ __ ] that's
good stuff in the mouth is well what's
it cost about $13 a $130 $14 for a roll
yeah
14:08 delicious delicioso
lobsters insects of the sea and
delicious logs of the sea brought to the
sea buddy [ __ ] scallywag legs here
left his [ __ ] coffee
hey delete does I'm sorry I'm sorry
after we look like your maids bro I
wouldn't be surprised if I saw Elliott
driving in his super expensive car his
new Chi wagon and Venus Sosa I wouldn't
be surprised if I just saw him casually
dump a bunch of mcdr a whole just eg
later later he take McDonald's eating
like a like just say it was a happy meal
I could just see him gone man and just
and just lazily letting it fall like a
literally throw it he would just litter
bug out litter but I can wait till last
time you saw someone litter it's been a
hot minute ah you know what I saw
somebody a week ago on in Marina del Rey
how do you yep and two older women
two [ __ ] older women little bats
don't give a [ __ ] bro and they were in a
Mercedes so long Mercedes in the [ __ ]
just threw all I'm sorry to call her a
[ __ ] but a student group no dude
you have to start using okay I don't
really use that word either I know a
style bender using a lot so I feel like
maybe let's talk about him as an English
thing
well he's I know yeah but let's not use
blue bar [ __ ] so this [ __ ] says she
just she littered she threw she threw it
out on the street I was like what no why
why she's leaving this earth soon she
doesn't care it's like when you rent in
a house the hole in the wall you go [ __ ]
you're leaving soon yeah dub Davidoff
says he I can't wait till I'm 80 I'm
just gonna steal [ __ ] what are you gonna
do I saw an 80 year old to steal candy I
really did didn't didn't report him he
just reached in and put a bunch of my
some in his pocket I was like I wonder
what age you get like that cuz you ever
seeing the ER team Larry King like
there's you just farts now like you'll
just be sitting there is what no one
asked I want to ask cat and chin
something did did somebody dip you guys
in adorable sauce this morning because
you guys are just adorable
what okay I'm question wow you pre yeah
that was my question
oh okay um I had a dream about Chan yes
I had a dream about him I get to the
[ __ ] podcast and there are men in
suits and they go are you aware that he
is being investigated oh no or a serial
a series of serial killings oh well so I
I go okay and then I go let me get
Brennan out of there because you were in
danger Noel and I in danger so I I my
dream was I'm looking over chin I'm
going hey I need you try like this yeah
and you're like what and you keep making
the sudden movements for whatever reason
we knew that sudden movements were gonna
sparked we're gonna get you killed your
chin yeah I was like like and that it
was a night it was actually a nightmare
of me going like dad what do you go
what's going on like I kept hiding so
you would turn around so you couldn't
see me dude if we did find the kid 3d
that would for sure again season 100%
would be the theory is there any way we
can revive that I told you I was with
there was a couple that was boring me
Merida is when my wife is super
embarrassed like you she's like and they
were boring me and I was in a bad mood
and I was like I did I had just met them
we were we were talking and then I was
calling and I was just like you know I'm
people were drinking and I was just like
you know what I go like
like oh you know what gay just to mix it
up if you have pulled a wild card she
goes oh my gosh your wife did she was
I've never seen her get more red she hit
her handsome what is the kid with the
guys they were this couple was like well
kept power through it like there you go
girls like it happens
the only time I've been super
embarrassed when I rip the fart was I've
staying at clops house you might you
know club and with his girlfriend she'd
they were just she just moved into his
house and I was staying there cuz I was
in training camp and I was like they
were just like feeling each other out
and we were watching I forget someone TV
and had to fart so bad but I'm not you
know I'm not doing for them as a girl
and she was like can you hand me down
like yeah I would go like this I did
this because right in my face gets so
red I just I wanted to die I wanted to
die yeah I want to be I and yours I
think so you don't want to feel like you
know and she just goes oh and then
pretend she's looking for something is
oh well and I went I'm gonna so just
real climate I'm gonna go on schooled I
was in waiting for my scene I kept
having to run out come back and I'm in
the scene and I'm sitting in the back
room and it's empty and then there's the
other set that's like with the window
which is my office and I was just like I
was like all right I gotta fart and I
pushed my butt out like okay short
shorts yes hard as I could I go yeah and
then I look up and a woman's honor her
phone she was I just I where I look down
like nothing happened and I ran away I'm
not going I can't I can't be avoided oh
yeah this is so imperative so
embarrassing I don't know what that is
hilarious
I'll call people out to like from in an
airport waiting to board the plane or if
I'm in an elevator or at a restaurant
and so on rip just a terrible fart
there's hot girls around
obviously I'm the big dude so they're
automatically like well he definitely
party here but it's never me yeah so I
make sure everyone knows like dick who
did that can you guys smell that and
like yeah I can't wait who the [ __ ]
would do that yeah I'm
sure that I'm kind of the fart general I
know on the fart general but you know
did that cuz I'm the fart general part
yeah but I did our Boyd Joe quois
podcast yesterday yes the nicest guys in
the world
he's the best man you know boys a beast
what's been hilarious - is it calm he
made me laugh so hard we're talking
about you're talking about comedy and
how we're just talking about how
sometimes we can be negative and like
everyone compares themselves to others
and how stupid it is and I said yeah
like being dead serious we like having a
heartfelt moment ago yeah like if I sell
out the Wilbur it doesn't affect you
sell out the Wilbur like if I sell out
once you sell out seven and I thought I
recall him selling out like multiple
times oh you sell out seven it doesn't
affect me I can come back the next month
and it's a good for everyone we
shouldn't compete and he goes yeah seven
you thirteen though excuse me this was
13 in a row oh shoot 13 Oreos yeah he
said seven I was like oh yeah yeah so
sick tickets and that happened when
Netflix finally put his special on the
air because they didn't for a long time
do you know the story with that
no so Netflix passed on it and he shot
it himself and then told Netflix Netflix
you can have it like I don't need to be
on that foot yes he was big before that
though yeah it was a Netflix I was like
you and you know game shows sell of a
shitload before Joe's a great comic not
a good one a great one he's always been
an Isis diver yeah he's always been
[ __ ] hilarious dude he's always been
super supportive of me yeah he's a great
guy he's a great gun always been a silly
goose
always been a great guy I don't see him
enough he's one of those guys I don't
know he's so busy
come on anything oh yes she has a pot
yeah I'll be on there they said me too
but god I want a mom that would sells
serious ticket yes he does
yes he does come see me in West Palm
Beach speaking of which mmm-hmm
yeah and then he was a restaurant I
think his sister runs it it's in Vegas
oh really
and then his brother-in-law is his
co-host on the podcast
damn that's pretty cool man keeping it
in the family
keep Manning in the family yeah that's
one of our fire to kid jackets I'm gonna
send him one yeah you gotta do that yeah
yeah I don't really see see him around
the comi stone no no I think when you
sell that many tickets to make that much
money you don't need to do the Comedy
Store you're like I'm he's on the road
so much he's I come and stay home you
think ya can have co-op there's some
guys who don't you don't really see like
you don't see doing the sets like the
Rogen does or like Billy is there every
night yeah but Ilya is crazy cuz Thalia
kirsta Lea is crazy good crazy lady Lea
has to do a set every night because he's
crazy
ain't that right Chris ain't you a
little cuckoo bird who needs to pee but
it's war know that you know him you know
what the common story you know what
stage is for Chris it's his [ __ ]
pacifier
it's his blankie ain't that right Chris
sorry dude um kind of went hard on him
when you see my back I pull myself up
like a champ 30 times while talking to
you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift